ellen degeneres
still under fire for alleged
mistreatment in the workplace at her
daytime talk show
now e.t is learning more about the
situation and how it's being handled
internally her brother actor vince
degeneres says his sister is being
viciously attacked by the media cycle as
more celebrities continue to speak out
tony yes is it hot over there because
your pants are on fire
when the ellen degeneres show first
launched in 2003
her on-air sidekick was dj tony okungboa
he appeared on and off for a total of
nine years
he's like my brother from another mother
tony addressed the allegations against
ellen and her staff on instagram
tuesday admitting he felt the toxicity
of the environment
and adding that he stands with his
former colleagues in their quest to
create a healthier and more
inclusive workplace you're always
thinking about everyone else
and we wanted to show you that people
are thinking about you
but ashton kutcher is one of many stars
like kevin hart and katy perry
speaking out in ellen's defense the
actor took to twitter on tuesday to
share that he's only had positive
experiences with the talk show host and
her team
writing quote she never pandered to
celebrity which i always saw as a
refreshing honesty
when things aren't right she handles it
and fixes
e.t spoke with jerry o'connell on
tuesday he says he's been friends with
ellen and wife portia de rossi for 30
years
i believe all all victims i believe all
stories
and obviously something has to change
uh at um in that work environment
yeah um but uh i do
love portia and ellen i do a source
recently opened up to e.t about ellen's
great relationship with celebrities but
when it comes to her team
the source said quote in the time i've
spent there the staff was definitely
running around in fear
there's a very negative and fearful vibe
from the staff
you know i think that i was a nice
person to begin with and i hope i've
gotten nicer
in the wake of the misconduct
allegations leveled against ellen and
her executive staff
e.t is learning more about what's going
on behind the scenes
a source explains that ellen has been
very tuned out
over the past few years noting possible
fatigue
from doing the show for such a long time
but the source acknowledges that while
ellen can't be expected to hold
everyone's hand
it's still her production quote her name
is on the door and that means
everything leadership comes from the top
sure
sometimes people walk on eggshells
around her but she's the boss
i don't think you achieve anything by by
bullying people
as for how things are being handled
internally well et
has learned that a virtual staff meeting
was held on monday
to update employees on the current
investigation surrounding claims of
workplace misconduct
we're told there are staff members who
feel optimistic about
positive change ahead and more
involvement from ellen
who plans to start shooting new episodes
in september for the new season
you